when I first started hearing about
self-care the first thing that came to
my mind was grooming and personal
hygiene and while bubble baths can
certainly be a form of self-care I also
think it's often the tiny seemingly
insignificant changes we make day to day
that truly end up changing our lives in
the long run it's often the mindset
shifts and the emphasis we place on our
mental and spiritual health that make
long-lasting effects so today I will
share with you 12 tiny self-care habits
that you can do most of these in under
two minutes to truly change your life
and be sure to stick to the end for the
one that I believe has been a total Game
Changer since I began to put it into
practice also share your own self-care
tips and hacks down in the comments
below so that we can make this one huge
list of self-care ideas number one is to
step outside or change your environment
when you're stressed during my first
postpartum experience I had the baby
blues bad I would cry all the time and I
felt tremendous feelings of overwhelm
and feelings of inadequacy and one of
the things that I found very helpful for
me was to physically step outside for
just a few minutes when I felt my
emotions bubbling like a pot about to
spill over when I've been angry with
someone I found it incredibly helpful to
physically step away before responding
maybe in another room maybe outside or
maybe that means putting my phone away
before I react to a specific
conversation because by allowing myself
to have a physical change in scenery I
allow myself the chance to regain calm
and regain mental Clarity when our
toddler struggled with emotional
outbursts and intense anxiety due to
hypersensitivity one of the things that
Rudy loved to do was to take her outside
for just a couple of minutes and nine
times out of ten her anxiety would
greatly reduce and she would step back
inside with a completely changed
expression former U.S Secret Service
agent Evie pomperas talks about this in
her book becoming bulletproof often a
change in scenery can allow your
emotions to rise and fall like a wave in
the ocean without causing any harm to
either other people around you or
perhaps even yourself number two 2 is to
correct your posture if you struggle
with self-confidence adopt the habit of
regularly checking in on your posture
this definitely goes for me too sit up
or stand up straight roll your shoulders
back and lift your chin poor posture
decreases your lung capacity making it
so that you don't breathe in as deeply
it places stress on your body it throws
you off balance and can even contribute
to tension headaches and while good
posture can be great on a physiological
level it can actually help boost your
confidence I'm definitely a work in
progress on this one as it takes a lot
of practice if it's something that
you're not used to but don't give up on
it your body will thank you for it years
down the road and not only will you look
more confident but through good posture
you can actually become so number three
is to smile when you don't feel like it
when I first heard about the
physiological effect of smiling I
thought it was Hocus Pocus it felt silly
to smile when I'm feeling frustrated or
upset about something but as strange as
it sounds it works when you smile a
chemical action occurs in your brain
your brain releases neuropeptides which
help you fight off stress and it also
has an effect on your neurotransmitters
like dopamine serotonin and endorphins
which make you feel happy think of
children and how Carefree they tend to
be and you'll realize that they smile
and laugh about the silliest things
maybe you're not happy right now smile
and smile often and make those brain
juices work for you number four is small
wins before bed I don't know about you
but I've often ruminated over issues in
my life and it either tends to end up
that I end up having a difficult time
getting to sleep or I just have poor
Sleep Quality in general something that
I've been doing for a couple of years
now is to consciously think of my small
wins or my favorite parts of the day
before bed especially when it's been a
horrible day so in our family it's kind
of become the norm to ask each other
what our favorite parts of the day were
or our small wins before we go to bed my
husband Rudy hates when I ask him this
on a bad day because he's forced to
think of something good that happen that
day and sometimes it's easier to stay
stuck in our emotions but night time is
especially that time when we want to
wind down relax and not be so hard on
ourselves consciously thinking of the
tiny things that went right that day can
help us create a more positive growth
focused mindset and it can do wonders to
help decrease our anxiety and help us
sleep easier at night which can in turn
help us give our best shot the next day
if you're struggling with a major issue
congratulating yourself for the tiny
things like I took out the garbage today
or I opened the door for an elderly
woman at the store it slowly turns you
into your own cheerleader so be kind to
yourself and tonight when you go to bed
mentally high-five yourself for your
small wins number five is gratitude
first thing in the morning this can seem
like work or just another thing to add
to your to-do list if it's something
that you're not used to start your day
on a positive note just like riding
small wins at night can help you see
that even on a rainy day there's still
something to be happy about taking the
time to consciously list out a few
things that you're thankful for can
start your day off on the right foot how
many times have you gotten up angry at
your alarm for interrupting your sleep
or annoyed because it's Monday and you
have to go to work what if you wake up
that day being grateful that you're
healthy that you have a car to get you
to where you need to go that you have
supportive people in your life or if you
don't that you have internet access to
thousands or millions of inspiring
people that can be your virtual mentors
I was recently reminded of this quote
that I read and it could not describe it
any better some say that the grass is
greener on the other side the grass is
greener where you water it number six is
to make your bed every single day this
takes very minimal effort but it's so
important for developing positive habits
because the first thing that we do after
we wake up is a small win if nothing
else goes right that day at the very
least our bed was made and something in
our life has order if you feel like your
home or your personal life is chaotic
make it a habits and make your bed every
single day it can not only help you
increase discipline but an added benefit
is that it also makes it less tempting
to get back in the bed once you've
already gotten up number seven is to
take a cold shower after you wake up I
get it cold showers may not be for
everyone and you're probably thinking
that it sounds more like torture than
self-care I've been taking cold showers
for about two months now and I assure
you that if you've never done it before
you will start to do them at Marathon
speed but taking cold showers has been
shown to increase dopamine levels for
even hours after taking them it can help
improve your discipline boost your
cognitive function and improve your
focus and one of the things that I have
personally loved about it is that it
instantly wakes me up in the morning and
I honestly feel more refreshed
afterwards kind of like the effect of
placing cold cucumber slices on your
eyes if you struggle to wake up mentally
in the morning even just lowering the
temperature towards the end of your
shower can be an instant wake-up call so
if you're up for the challenge try it
out and let me know how it goes but if
you're thinking no way Jose I love my
hot showers that is totally fine it's
just that for me I cannot take a warm
shower in the morning because because I
find them too relaxing if I were to take
a warm shower it's usually at night to
relax before bed I can no longer
tolerate a hot shower no way that is not
for me number eight is super simple and
it's one that we've all know and have
heard about before drink more water I'm
a big fan of intermittent fasting and
over the years I've done several
extended fasts like two days three days
and even omad and because of that I can
definitely vouch that at least for me
sometimes when I feel like I'm in a
munching mood where I'm not necessarily
hungry but I'm just wanting to eat all
day long it tends to be because I
haven't had enough water and I'm
actually thirsty rather than hungry if
you struggle with Cravings try
increasing your water intake and you may
find that you were dehydrated you may
end up with more energy increase mental
Clarity and who knows maybe even reduce
Cravings number nine is to set app
limits on your phone and use night mode
I have an entire playlist devoted to
having balance with our technology and
social media and I find that for me
prioritizing time without screens and
having limits on my phone where
unnecessary apps aren't available after
a certain time and do not disturb
automatically turns on at night has
really helped me to improve my sleep at
night and just in general having breaks
from technology can be really helpful to
kind of ground us and put us back into
reality I'll link to the playlist at the
end of this video but if you want tips
on how to improve sleep specifically
check out my video on how to wake up at
5am it's packed with helpful tips to
help you become more productive while
getting a better night's rest and while
we're on the topic of Sleep Number 10 is
to set your alarm 15 minutes earlier if
you find yourself constantly in a rush
to get ready in the morning try turning
back your alarm just 15 minutes earlier
and put your alarm across the room to
force you to get out of the bed in the
morning when it rings this way you can
take it slow and treat yourself to
actually sitting down for breakfast or
if there's a lot of traffic or you
spilled milk all over the floor hence no
sweat off your back because you get gave
yourself some extra time making your
mornings go a lot smoother and starting
your day on a positive note by
eliminating that hectic Rush number 11
is to perform an act of kindness taking
care of ourselves also means taking care
of the ones around us when we do
something nice for someone else and make
someone else's day it has an infectious
effect on us as well doing kind things
for others can boost our levels of
oxytocin the love hormone which can
boost our mood and overall happiness
when you put it this way it kind of
makes it seem selfish like doing kind
things for other people is really just
because you want to feel warm and fuzzy
inside but as an old Mentor used to say
it is good business being good to others
and lastly my favorite on this list is
to have it stack for positive vibes so
think of those activities that you dread
or you hate doing but you can't avoid
doing and find ways to inject some
positivity and joy into those activities
for example for years I hated winter
because days are already shorter and
because I live near a lake it's almost
always either rainy or just cloudy for
days on end it's like Dracula moves into
Georgia in the winter time so this past
winter I added fairy lights with a timer
and I play relaxing piano music and now
on rainy days I actually want to be home
because I find it super cozy another
example is that I typically wake up
around 5am which for most of us isn't
exactly something pleasing to do but
something that I really look forward to
that motivates me to get out of the bed
in the mornings is my morning collagen
latte sometimes it's matcha coffee chai
turmeric you name it it really doesn't
matter there's something cozy and
comforting to me and a warm drink in the
morning before my kids wake up
it's my me time and it gives me a lot of
joy in something that would otherwise
not be as much fun back when I worked a
7 PM to 7 A.M shift and had an hour and
a half sometimes even two hour long
commute in city traffic I used to call
my now husband via Bluetooth on my rides
back home in the mornings this one made
my days a little bit brighter because I
had something to look forward to on that
commute and two it easily kept me and
others around me alive because I had no
idea how I got home some days I was so
exhausted I hated night shift with a
passion but adding this tiny habit kept
me awake and it made my commute slightly
less horrible maybe you hate commuting
to work try finding a cool podcast or
audiobook to listen to on your commute
this can not only keep you entertained
but more importantly it can help you
learn and grow maybe you don't like
cleaning try putting on your favorite
songs from when you were younger and
reminisce on the good times or dances
you clean and think of cleaning as your
workout we all have things that we don't
necessarily enjoy doing but we have to
do anyway so think of those tasks that
you do regularly and inject Positive
Vibes to them after a while you may
actually end up liking these things for
even better results actually write these
things down make a list of your
necessary but most dreaded tasks and jot
down any ideas of how you can make these
just a little bit brighter this is an
awesome way to make them mundane
extraordinary
that's all I have for today's video I
thank you so much for sticking to the
end and if you like this video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel if you'd like to see
more videos on minimalism and slow
living also be sure to hit that
subscribe button and hit that
notification Bell so you won't miss when
I post a new video if there's any
particular videos you'd like to see
either send me an email or put it down
in the comments below I thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now